on April 28 2022 Christian kazadi posted
this photo from Botswana to Instagram
calling it a bucket list experience the
29 year old entrepreneur and founder was
in the country attending the first ever
Forbes under 30 Africa Summit but in a
mysterious and baffling sequence of
events kazadi was found dead in police
custody over one thousand miles away in
Kinshasa the capital of the Democratic
Republic of the Congo
one year later kazadi's family are still
looking for an official explanation to
why a dream business trip ended in a
nightmare
[Music]
Christine kazali was a 29 year old
entrepreneur and founder of a social
media and digital marketing agency based
in Johannesburg South Africa called
click media Productions he founded it a
few years ago you know one of his dreams
was to appear on the Forbes 30 under 30
list for 2022 he had applied to the
Forbes Africa 30 under 30 list and as
part of the application even though he
didn't make it onto the final list he
was invited to go to the first ever
Forbes 30 under 30 Africa Summit in
Botswana which took place at the end of
April of last year it was something that
was basically well known in in the
states like social media management
managing clients social media and all
that it's not something that's very very
well known in Africa it's something
that's probably well known in the States
because you guys originated it and you
guys basically create all of these apps
and it's a market that's very viable in
the state but in Africa it's not that
viable like all not all corporate
companies like socials or anything like
that they don't have Google appraisers
they don't have seos so that was the
field that Chris saw a gap in and he was
like oh let's build a company and let me
Chase that because it was something that
he was well knowledge in and he loved
social media and he understood social
media and one of the first big breaks
was in 2017 when he helped do social
media content for the NBA Africa game
which basically brought some of the
NBA's biggest stars at the time to
Johannesburg Dirk Nowitzki was there
Sergey black uh
um well dang there's also a photo of
Chris with Chris Paul as well
[Music]
the Forbes under 30 Africa Summit ended
the same day Christian posted his last
photo to Instagram he stayed in Botswana
for another two days before returning to
South Africa on April 30th Christian
arrived in Johannesburg at 10 45 a.m on
an airbot swanna flight but was denied
entry by immigration he was born in the
Democratic Republic of the Congo but in
2001 he immigrated to South Africa with
his mother and brothers to join his
father and they sought Asylum as
refugees
Christian had never returned to Congo
since then
do you remember when you heard from him
that he was having trouble entering and
if he had any idea why it happened I
know that in past times he had left
South Africa and come back without any
issue do you remember sort of wedding he
told you about that and what was going
on then I had scanned copies of his
passports and his work visa Sunday
morning the first message he saved me is
like April send me those copies I was
like okay no problem
I sent him the copies and then I waited
a while I waited a while and then I
missed him again I was like yo what's up
what time are you Landing when should we
come get you at that time I hadn't known
he had landed already but they're not
giving him problem they're saying his
work permit uh is invalid his work
permits invalid and that's the issue he
was having so that's why he asked me to
send you those documents we saw his work
visa a photocopy of it and the work visa
was valid it ran from 2020 until 2023.
so it was valid at that time according
to the latest human rights report on
South Africa published by the U.S state
Department unfortunately it's not
uncommon for immigrants in South Africa
Asylum Seekers to face difficulties at
the border re-entering and it seems like
that's what occurred to Christian that
day he told me that they were holding
him in a holding cell because I think
it's it's procedure in terms of people
person comes and date documents not
right he advised that the best thing to
do in that situation would be to
basically go back to Congo and go to the
Department and have them sorted out
immediately and you'd be back like
within a day
on May 1st Christian decided to go to
the Congo to sort out the work permit
issue he missed his initial flight to LA
bambashi and was booked on a later
flight to Kinshasa with a layover in
Ethiopia the plan was to then fly from
Kinshasa to LA bambashi and deal with
the work permit there as La mumbashi is
closer to Johannesburg and one of
Christian's Brothers happened to be
there sorting out passport issues to
travel to the U.S Christian arrived in
Kinshasa just after midnight on May 2nd
and sent a text message to Patrick at
1am Patrick says he saw the message when
he woke up at 4am and responded
around 9 A.M that Monday now that's when
a friend of ours who was supposed to
receive him at the airport calls me on
video call and is with Chris so then
that's what Chris tells me is like oh no
I planned it and everything's all right
so like an hour later the friendly was
worth calls me again on video call and
he's like yo Pat do me a favor check up
on Chris so I'm like what do you mean
he's like he was with Chris just now and
Chris looks a bit shaken up and he had
bruises on his hands and then I'm like
nah I don't understand what do you mean
it's like last night he didn't pick up
Chris because he was supposed to
actually fetch Chris at the airport is
like Crystal and call him when he
arrived Chris only called in this
morning so that's why he didn't asked
him I was like yo do you know where he
slipped and stuff like that he also
didn't know where Chris spent the night
but Chris only called him this morning
and when he arrived Chris already had
two other people waiting for him in a
separate car Chris told him that no he
got out he's going with these people
because apparently they knew the way it
was something like that at this point
the plan was for Chris and to come back
to the airport later in the afternoon to
catch his next flight and land in
limbashi around 6 PM but later that
evening Patrick began to worry as he
found out from a family friend that was
supposed to pick up Christian at the
airport in limbabashi that Christian was
not on the flight this family friend
messages Patrick Christian's brother
this video that a big uncirculating
showing Christian acting erratically
very bizarrely at a funeral where he
appears to be getting inside a casket
and shouting and then he's sort of
pulled away and arrested and this was
completely out of the ordinary for
someone like Christian and it was
extremely unclear to the family at that
time why Christian hadn't been picked up
by that family friend what had happened
in the ensuing hours so when I saw that
I was mad confused I was like no man
what's going on here because at first I
thought no that can't be him but then I
looked at his clothing I was like that's
definitely he's floating that is him so
then I was confused I was like okay this
is very very very weird and bizarre so
when I see that the first thing that
comes to mind I'm thinking I'm like this
person is not in his right State of Mind
like this is basically his eyes even are
not like focused or anything like you
can see he's not aware of the
surroundings typo anyway that he is and
the things he's doing uh uncoordinated
this is not Chris in any sense of the
word they eventually learned he had been
held in a military Detention Center on
the out skirts of Kinshasa that night
someone with this family friend who was
supposed to pick up Christian went to
the Detention Center speak with the
guards there it was late at night past
10 pm the guards told him that Christine
kazadi had been arrested there and was
being held there but they weren't able
to see him because the visiting hours
were over also he wasn't a member of the
family so he wouldn't have been able to
see him anyway so at that same time also
I do not share the news with moms
because that's definitely going to freak
her the hell out so I keep putting
myself in a wedding the family actually
knows so that whole night I just sit
back and I pray and I pray I pray that
night
on the morning of May 3rd the friend in
limbashi told Patrick that he knows a
general who works at the camp where
Christian is being held the friend
received an update from his contact and
phoned Patrick
so he's like oh Pat I'm so sorry and
whatnot I'm sorry to let you know this
I'm like what do you mean and he's like
nah Chris has been found but he's dead
and now I'm shocked I'm like what do you
mean Chris is dead and he's like no
Chris is dead his body has been found
and it's out it's outside the police
station and he was murdered
what's his body doing outside the police
station if this guy was in the police
cell so now I'm just trying to get a
hold of everybody in teeny and while I'm
trying to get a hold of them that's when
this guy sends me the video
of Chris's lifeless body laying there
and they recorded him that was just like
confirmation to basically and then from
the video you can see that this person
has been beaten beats and beats and
beats and beaten
[Music]
the questions that are still an answer
today are you know why wasn't Christian
able to re-enter South Africa what
happened to him on that day that he was
in Congo why was he at that funeral
why was he arrested what happened to him
at the detention center and then how did
he die and those are the questions that
unfortunately despite the investigation
ongoing in Congo and the public records
request filed by his family in South
Africa and the you know dozens of calls
and efforts to reach out to people both
the police and Congo and the ministry in
South Africa those are the questions
that we still haven't been able to
answer now more than a year after his
tragic death
in the days after Christian's death I
called
at least a dozen officials at the home
Affairs Ministry and the airport over
multiple days and eventually what we
were you know recommended to do was to
file a public records request in South
Africa in July of 2022 Kristin's family
his mother and brother filed this public
records request and under South African
law
government agencies must respond within
30 days and they can apply for one
extension only of another 30 days and
it's now been several months since July
of last year the ministry has told me
and his family repeatedly
that they will have a response they but
they have never responded to the request
and haven't provided any information on
why Christian was an admitted entry last
year Christian's family hired a lawyer
in Congo to follow the case
he initially was able to sort of track
down the police officers that were in
charge of the case however they told him
that they couldn't find the actual case
File the case File that that you know
showed which officers were being
investigated for what happened to
Christian he definitely did not have any
business enemies because what he was
pushing was his own lane it's not like
he's doing Mining and he'd be
competition with the other mind that has
been around no social media is something
that nobody had Lita has here and the
people that are doing it actually like
competition because what you do is you
let the next people know that this is
important
foreign
by Patrick Chris's brother who runs the
company as CEO he was one of the
co-founders back in 2016 and his role
while Chris was was still here and was
still leading the company was more of a
back room role managing the operations
and the business side while Chris was
really the public face the one getting
the clients and maintaining the
relationships since Chris is passing he
set to face the difficulties of
retaining clients and growing the
company in the face of the conspiracy
theories that were spread about Chris
and his death it's a smear campaign
where everybody's like yeah he's a wage
he's a witch and he deserved what came
to him and he deserved what came to him
so that whole thing also messed up his
reputation because even his close
friends everybody business and to watch
everybody because at first people are
shocked Christian died Christian the
Christian we know Christian died people
are sympathetic and if that story comes
out and then everybody just backs away
so all of his friends business partners
everybody starts backing away and this
associating themselves with him so that
whole thing was also a dilemma for my
mom because now she's trying to warn her
child but she's being attacked in terms
of yeah you sacrificed your child you
were teaching your child Witchcraft and
stuff like that I spoke to several
musicians that uh Chris represented I
collect media who are able to get their
music out there a lot more and become a
lot more a lot better known and have a
lot more success in the years after they
worked with Chris and click media and he
touched so many lives through not just
his work with click media but also as
his brother Patrick has told me many
times the fact that he was always
willing to help even at the cost of
taking time out of his own day and his
own work for me the thing that hurts me
the most is Chris never came back from
Forbes for me he never came back like we
had planned that whole trip of dog you
made it you made it because they show
these people and come back and let's
replay and let's restructure he never
came back he respected you guys and he
went to you guys basically to Showcase
and let you guys know that hey I'm out
here and you guys will hear a lot more
from me as time goes on and everybody
else has failed because everybody has
failed foreign
[Music]